hey leute was glaubt und jetzt
willkommen beim ein video hätte ich
hoffe euch geht's gut leute kommt man
mit kommt man mit kommt man mit bus hält
hier heute alter manier in kürze egal
ich war auf jeden fall vor drei vier
tagen oder so noch in köln beim dm fragt
mich am besten gar nicht was dort
gemacht habe auf jeden fall habe ich
wirklich mega durch zufall einfach hier
somit war es und zwar ist es hier impuls
melina sophie special edition shop wurde
so irgendwie habe ich auch nur das
gefunden warum ich mir das einfach mal
gekauft haben weil sie sich selber nicht
mehr also ich wollte einfach mal
mitnehmen vielleicht kann man damit ja
irgendwas anfang im video sohn dann habe
ich heute morgen auf install angesehen
das ist das nicht nur von melina sophie
gibt sondern auch von carola maria dabei
natürlich auf die unfassbar toll das ist
mein auto zu gefragt dankeschön auf
jeden fall bin ich auf die unfassbar
tolle idee gekommen mal so ein live
tests machen welches dann besser ist man
klar das ist natürlich eigentlich eher
für frauen oder mädchen gedacht aber ihr
seid ihr schon so dumme sachen von mir
gewohnt also das heißt folgendes wir
fahren jetzt doch los kaufen dann noch
das andere ich hoffe ich kriege das
überhaupt und wir kaufen auch noch die
blue shampoo edition und dann habe ich
drei teile weil bis jetzt gibt es ja von
youtube drin nur bio
jetzt kommen noch zwei andere sachen auf
den markt und ihr test jetzt mal ob die
genauso gut sind ich weiß auch nicht wie
ich das genau testen soll rice vergleich
vielleicht könnte ich mir doch einfach
mal in die haare schmieren ich meine was
ist dabei wichtig danach wenigstens gute
leute also wir sehen uns gleich wieder
bis leicht so leute geil wie du kannst
du das mal kurz schau stellen cremiger
du schauen
ich weiß jetzt aber gar nicht ob das
schon grüße ich glaub nicht oder falsch
so herzlich willkommen zurück hier aus
meinem badezimmer und genäht herzlich
willkommen zu alex wie beauty stunde
also wer mafia special edition ich habe
werde ich jetzt meine hand die
endhaltestelle das schaffst du blickst
du wirst vom duft nach mehreren großen
und kirschblüten träume in berlin aber
von trennt die luft nach
ideen wie kann man ein baby träumt von
geld und ach so ich glaube ich habe
jetzt hier das ist kein shampoo das ist
schauen so leute ziel das heutige videos
ist jeden charme auszuprobieren und am
ende sage ich welcher blöd ist und
welche gutes meine alle drei plötzlich
sah ich das natürlich auch also ich will
ehrlich sein ich möchte ich dass sie
einen quatsch kauft ja und jetzt bin ich
erst mal gespannt wie das aussieht ich
mal in folge im test wir haben jetzt
noch ganz ultra normales shampoo für 99
cent also dass hier richtet sich
wirklich schlechter aber dass ihr nicht
mehr so nach so ein bisschen nach so ein
bisschen frucht sommer mäßig hat
übrigens 275 gekostet und ich habe
gerade gesehen davon gibt es auch noch
dem also da wird einiges auf den markt
geschmissen das habe ich jetzt aber erst
noch nicht mitgenommen also ich bin ich
mal gespannt wie es aussieht das ist ja
das ist halt jetzt wenig ist in der
farbe oder so riecht irgendwie die ganz
normalen das shampoo sodass sie hat auch
zu eur 75 gekostet das ist
wahrscheinlich auch einfach weiß er hat
es den jetzt zum kürzen
heute machen also das war das für ein
paar oder und das sind also das recht
auf jeden fall schon unterschiedlich
neulich hat jetzt wenigstens gedacht
dass vielleicht das eine boot ist und
das andere blau
das ist irgendwie nicht so einen
stellenwert hat wirklich die frage ob
ich damit jetzt mal meine haare waschen
soll ich hoffe ich kann das und die arme
machen eigentlich schon recht weiß
eigentlich kein shampoo sondern nur für
den körper wartet kurz ich muss jetzt
mal kurz schenken wie teuer das war 3
euro 95 das schon teuer
na ja heute mein ziel ist es jetzt
vielleicht dann darum die kamera zu
posieren
radierungen die kamera zu positionieren
und dann werde ich das einfach mal kurz
testen ich meine ich habe heute noch
nicht mehr duschen und wir lassen ja
sofort einfach 10.000 extra für diese
minimalen vier jahren gemacht habe
kleinert rest also das müsste eigentlich
gehen oder leute schuldig weil das daran
wie ich die kamera ihr positioniert habe
heftig oder hobbys was geht ich hoffe
ihr seid nicht mehr lang zu bringen sich
auf meine unterhose doch an also selbst
ein bisschen zu riskant für die
elefanten könnt ihr eure noch 5000
leichter lassen
den habe ich glaube ich einfach gemacht
also ich muss sagen ein bisschen das
kann ich meine kamera war nicht drin
jetzt schnell gefallen haben mit oder
oder maria richter oder barrieren haben
blüten
also ich würde auf jeden fall dass durch
das für 99 cent bevorzugen einfach ich
fühle mich gerade wie so ein rosenbeet
jack cover das von mir lieder haben ich
glaube schon dass auf jeden fall gut
hier zu nutze ich sagen dass ich da
nicht so extrem nach irgendwelchen
komischen ja früchten oder so
das könnte durchaus schaffen sein
so halten dass man innerhalb ja auf
jeden fall schon mal besser gefallen
wobei das gar nicht wie die haare ist
oder ich habe auf jeden fall ohne spaß
und nie wieder der dusche bedeutet auch
immer das wahrscheinlich nicht in die
hand gemacht dass jetzt einfach mal dass
ich gar nicht mehr so schlecht an
nachdem jetzt ohne spaß gehabt die
kamera darunter gefallen ist ehrlich die
ist komplett nach hinten ich habe das
rad auch zugehört haben einfach meinen
fuß nach hinten gemacht und dann ist ja
diesen kleinstadt hilfe und einfach auf
meinen fuß gefallen ich hatte ein
bisschen glück bei dass stative es
zuerst einmal fuß gefallen dann die
kamera nicht dass der auftakt aber sie
funktioniert
die leute jetzt wollt ihr sicherlich
wissen alex was ist denn ein
abschließendes resümee ja ich habe keins
alles scheiße haut
ich weiß aber ich muss sagen dass von
carola maria hat mir nicht gefallen
vermutlich meine vier geben das riecht
einfach zu intensiven nach irgendwelchen
chemikalien zeugs das von mir lieber
direkt ich ziemlich gut könnte man sogar
als mersch an wodurch gelassen weg von
mir acht punkte und das ist gar nicht
mal so schlecht ich halt auch ziemlich
intensiv nur auf einer eigentlich
ziemlich guten weise wäre das nicht so
teuer möchte auch nachts geben
darum gebe ich überhaupt noten ja ist
eine 6 für mich also das wäre meine
meinung er wollte so viele erstmals ein
thema welches video gefahr dass nur nach
oben da ich bin glücklich und ich habe
meine kamera gerettet und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder morgen um 14 uhr stellen
auf jeden fall stand schon im ennstal
und auf keinen fall vergessen wir sehen
uns morgen wieder auf